this video was made possible by our
friends over at class
- central.com / Pakman click the link
under this video to get access to
thousands of lectures from the world's
top universities many of which are
totally free whether you realize it or
not you might believe in some of the
superstitions I'm going to discuss with
you today we could define superstitions
as irrational beliefs that an object or
behavior has the power to influence an
outcome where there's no logical
connection between them very often
people believe superstitions for
underlying sort of pseudo scientific
reasons but there's also evidence that
suggests superstitious behavior is found
among all sorts of species and it might
even have been evolutionarily beneficial
in 1947 famed psychologist BF Skinner
performed an experiment which would
later become known as the superstition
experiment where he put hungry pigeons
under supervision and had the machine
fed at regular time intervals and over
time 75% of the pigeons started to
exhibit sort of ritualistic behavior
like they believed whatever action they
took before the feeding might have
caused the feeding to take place and
this was the first experiment to suggest
that it's not just humans that have
tendencies towards superstitious type
behavior evolutionary psychologist
suggests that superstitious behavior is
an inevitable feature of adaptive
behavior and that every organism could
be subject to it and they've theorized
that superstitious behavior usually has
little downside and the intuition behind
it might help survival in a few
different ways so the suggestion is that
being slightly superstitious is almost a
natural part of life for many species
and in fact sometimes it could have
benefits psychologists at the University
of Cologne and Germany found in a recent
study that Goodluck charms
can improve performance though the good
luck of these rituals and objects is
likely confirmation bias you
member when it works and attribute it to
the superstition when it doesn't work
you attribute it to something else
superstitions can also lead to a false
sense of security and that's been
observed in a study of South African
taxi drivers superstition in drivers was
positively related to the number of
accidents that they had been involved in
but instead of looking at the value of a
good luck charm or of taxi drivers in
South Africa I'm gonna focus in this
episode on some of society's most
colloquial and common superstition so
fear of the number 13 666 walking under
a ladder breaking a mirror opening an
umbrella inside blackcats spilling salt
saying god bless you' wishbones crossing
your fingers and knocking on wood so
let's get right into it
the number 13 has special significance
in our culture so much so that fear of
the number 13 has its own name
triskaidekaphobia
Hotels often have no 13th floor I guess
that's not really true they they have no
floor that they call the 13th there's
still a floor above the 12th no matter
what you call it but they don't have a
floor numbered 13 airports tend not to
have gate number 13 Friday the 13th is
easily the most superstitious day of the
year and like many of these
superstitions it's not exactly clear
where our aversion to the number 13
comes from but there are a few different
ideas one possibility is that there were
originally 12 people with Jesus at the
Last Supper Judas was the 13th disciple
to join Jesus that night and soon after
he would go on to betray Jesus in the
ancient Persian religion of
Zoroastrianism the number 13 has been
considered sinister and wicked for
thousands of years it's also been said
that there were 13 steps to the gallows
12 going up and one going down thomas
fern slur who works in the math and
science education research center at the
university of delaware says that 13 has
this awful place in our collective
imaginations simply because it comes
after 12 12 is a perfect number
mathematically and historically
significant the twelve gods of Olympus
12 months of the year twelve hours of
the clock twelve tribes of Israel
twelve apostles of Jesus it's all
arbitrary but there are these numbers in
human history but is there actually any
power in the number thirteen seems
extremely unlikely that thirteen holds
any significance outside the one we
suppose presuppose it to have in a few
cultures it's even thought of as
bringing luck not misfortune 666 is a
highly stigmatized number in culture
similar to 13 in its mystique 666 is
connected to the Bible specifically the
New Testaments book of Revelation it
refers to the number or name of a wild
beast whose relation with Satan and the
Antichrist is sort of unclear who's the
harbinger of the biblically foretold end
times rings of Bell based on some of the
interviews we've done it's not totally
clear what exactly 666 refers to is that
the name of the beast is it a number
associated with the length of the beasts
reign on earth or is it a cryptic
message to persecuted Christians living
in the Roman Empire as usual there is
not a clear answer from the Bible the
number of the beast is given in
Revelation 13 15 to 18 this part of the
Bible was likely written during the
reign of Nero the Roman Emperor and when
looking at his translated name in Hebrew
the letters which in Hebrew can also
have numeric values add up to 666 so
this sort of hints at the possibility
that this passage was code to Christians
at the time telling them that the Roman
Emperor and therefore the whole state by
extension was under a demonic Antichrist
influence people often caution others
about walking under ladders it's a smart
policy to be extra alert around ladders
regardless of good or bad luck because
someone might be on the ladder but
walking under it according to some
superstition has dangers associated with
it beyond just the risk of immediately
getting hurt and I'm referring of course
to the idea that walking underneath a
ladder causes bad luck in ancient Egypt
priests would sometimes Lee
ladders in tombs because it was believed
that spirits could use them to ascend
upwards in the Middle Ages people began
to associate ladders with the Gallo so
to walk underneath one could have been
to foreshadow your imminent death by
hanging there's also a third explanation
which is the Christian concept of
Trinity walking under a ladder disrupts
the natural Trinity associated with the
shape which I guess would somehow curse
you mirrors in the past were usually
very small and very expensive and
building a cultural taboo around
breaking them is almost sensible in the
sense that in populations were mirrors
were so rare and scarce
maybe the superstition about breaking
mirrors was about saving money because
they cost so much mirrors are no longer
so rare but yet the superstition still
remains there is this ancient belief
that projections of your physical self
contain a piece of your soul so if you
shatter a mirror
it could be believed that you shattered
a part of your soul in the process but
of course this superstition assumes that
number one souls are real number two
that they can be in multiple places at
once and number three that they could
somehow be trapped within a reflective
surface even though mirrors are flat and
have no depth whatsoever so once again
seems a little bit far-fetched when it's
raining outside people will often
mention it's unlucky to open umbrellas
if you're still in the house or indoors
one explanation for the superstition
comes from ancient Egypt where umbrellas
were used only by the elite but not so
much for rain but to shield themselves
from the Sun to open an umbrella inside
then was an insult to the Egyptian god
of the Sun raw but there's actually a
more sort of grounded explanation for
the umbrella superstition and it comes
from 18th century England this was the
first time period where umbrellas became
widely available but they were made with
very sharp metal spokes and frames which
would very rapidly expand when opened
this made it actually a potentially
dangerous and volatile action
to open an umbrella indoors in terms of
the risk that it would place other
people and objects at and maybe that's
the source of it a very common
superstition all throughout Western
culture and especially noticeable around
Halloween is the idea that black cats
are an ill omen black cat hysteria is so
bad that around Halloween many animal
shelters won't allow anybody to adopt
black cats because they fear that the
adopters will mistreat them around
Halloween medieval Europe was a place
where superstition was very plentiful
since there was very little education
available to much of the population and
this was a period during which witch
hunts were not unheard of I'm not
talking about investigating the
president for possible illegal
coordination with a foreign country I'm
talking about actual witch hunts and
relatedly the idea that black cats were
associated with the occult also started
then cats are known as nocturnal people
started to associate them with the devil
as a result and the superstition grew so
intense that people actually undertook
mass purges of black cats in Europe
let's talk about salt salt has been for
a very long time a really important food
item it's used for flavor it's used for
preservation it's been very valuable
throughout history and a common
superstition that surrounds salt is that
spilling it is an omen of misfortune and
the best way to counter this is to throw
a pinch of salt over your left shoulder
in an age where salt was rare and very
valuable it makes sense that norms would
develop around its use given its value
if you spilled some you were throwing a
lot of money away which would feel like
bad luck the other theory about this
superstitions origin actually comes from
Leonardo da Vinci and his famous
painting of the Last Supper because in
the picture we can see that Judas the
man who would go on to betray Jesus to
the Romans had spilled salt relating to
one of the most reviled men in history
with spilling salt may have helped to
spread the news that spilling salt is an
evil portent it's practically a reflex
for many when you hear someone sneeze
you hear god bless you
or some version of it for many people
it's just good manners but the origins
of the expression are very very firmly
rooted in superstition
one theory is that people used to think
that a sneeze was an attempt by the soul
to escape the body so if you bless the
person who sneezed you're protecting
their exposed soul from the devil who
might try to steal it in a moment of
opportunity there's another theory that
comes from the time when Europe was
being ravaged by plague
sneezing was thought to be one of the
first symptoms so in 590 C II Pope
Gregory the first ordered that those who
sneeze to be blessed immediately I don't
know if you have this tradition at your
house but around Thanksgiving it's a
common practice to remove the wishbone
from a turkey before you carve it once
dried two people make a wish
pull the bone from either side and
whoever has the bone break in their
direction supposedly has their wish
granted
this is a tradition believed to have
been inherited from the Romans who got
it from an Italian people they conquered
in antiquity the Etruscans who believed
that chickens were Oracle's who
predicted the future chickens would
often be sacrificed by the Romans and
the Etruscans their remains were
searched by priests for clues as to what
the future held and how this morphed
into being about turkeys and only the
wishbone isn't completely clear but what
is clear is that the power to grant the
desires of a Thanksgiving guest is
definitely not something that the
turkeys version of a clavicle bone would
accomplish next let's talk about
knocking on wood very common expression
common action to knock on wood
after potentially jinxing something the
action of knocking on wood keeps away
bad luck in pre-christian Europe people
worshipped spirits some of whom made
their homes in the trees and to pray to
these gods and often to ask for their
favor
people would lay their hands on the
trees to communicate in Christian
communities there's a belief that by
touching wood you're also somehow
touching the wood of the Cross and
therefore you're seeking the protection
of God there's one more explanation
about knocking on wood and it comes from
British folklore
Steve roud who claims that a 19th
century children's game known as tikki
touchwood is the progenitor to knocking
on wood the game functioned much like
modern tag except it was trees that were
the only safe zone superstitions are all
around us for many of us their use in
conversation comes so naturally that we
hardly even notice them these
superstitions some of which are even
considered rude not to adhere to come
from pre-modern understandings of the
world when you don't have science to
sort pattern from noise people's brains
jump to all sorts of conclusions to
explain what seems unexplainable today
we know more about the universe than
ever before we know that someone who
sneezes isn't having their soul leave
their body we know that breaking a
mirror is mostly a headache to clean up
rather than anything else and walking
under a ladder won't actually have any
effect on your life
many people take what's called a
Pascal's wager approach towards
superstition like those we've talked
about and what I mean by that is even
though it's really unlikely that
superstition would come true or be real
people choose to believe it just in case
in case that it's worth something if it
doesn't take a lot of effort economists
estimate that every Friday the 13th
millions of dollars are lost in business
and productivity some superstitious
Christians might refuse to pay a bill if
the total is reminiscent to the number
of the beast when we let superstitions
guide our decisions we surrender our
ability to think critically even though
we know all of these things to be true
superstitions still remain may be BF
Skinner was right and every creature who
survives by spotting patterns spots some
even when they don't exist but as the
only animal with the capacity for
intelligent thought maybe it's time we
move past the realm of superstition and
instead start to see the world for what
it is not the imaginary patterns that
superstition suggests if you're
interested in evolutionary psychology
the kind that plays a big role in the
development of superstition and you want
to find out more I would recommend
taking a free online course offered by
Kyoto University called origins
the human mind it's only one of tens of
thousands offered at class central.com
slash Pakman you can click the link
under this video start watching courses
from the most prestigious universities
in the world including Harvard MIT
Stanford Berkeley Oxford and hundreds of
others
they've got classes on politics
philosophy psychology business just
about any type of class you'd be able to
take at an actual University check it
out click the link in the description to
search for a class on a topic that
fascinates you that is class
- central.com /p a que ma n